l'aiguillage ce nom vous dit il quelque
chose
l'ancienne maison du garde barrière de
la ligne paris chartres a fait peau
neuve pour devenir en mars dernier la
maison du tourisme et de la mobilité
elle est située stratégiquement juste à
côté de la gare de saint rémy les
chevreuse et a pour but de promouvoir
l'activité touristique du parc géré par
la société et cox dans le cadre du pôle
éco mobilité de la vallée de chevreuse
elle offre différents services pour les
particuliers et pour les entreprises
alors il ya deux activités dans cette
maison il ya l'office du patrimoine qui
est au dessus à laitages nous qui est
vraiment là pour aiguiller tous les
touristes qui sont là pour vraiment
découvrir le parc donc c'est vraiment un
but touristique
et nous qui sommes aussi là pour
développer l'activité qu'on appelle
écomobilité donc entre autres le
tourisme à vélo dans dans le parc
location et vente de vélos 90 places de
stationnement pour vélos location de
véhicules électriques
la société cherche à attirer le plus
grand nombre d'adhérents
pour cela elle mis sur une autre facette
la réparation de vélos dont vous propose
deux grandes familles de vélos qui sont
les vélos à assistance électrique et les
vélos classiques
on peut aussi appeler vélo musculaire en
danse evènement ces deux grandes
familles on propose des vélos urbains
vraiment des vélos de ville qu'on peut
appeler aussi des vélos de femmes au col
de cygne donc vraiment adapté pour
rouler sur la route les pistes cyclables
typiquement quelqu'un qui s'en sert pour
aller au marché
enfin voilà des déplacements urbains on
a des vtc donc ça c'est des vélos un peu
plus polyvalents qui peuvent tout aussi
bien rouler sur la route piste cyclable
et sur les petits chemins de terre
c'est ça passe quand même relativement
partout et on a les vtt donc là par
contre c'est vraiment adapté à une
pratique un peu plus sportives ou en
tout cas qui passe beaucoup mieux en
forêt à ça on rajoute
une proposition de sièges enfants de
petite remorque pour les enfants et puis
bientôt aussi des vélos pour enfants
l'aiguillage de saint rémy les chevreuse
vient s'ajouter à une dizaine d'autres
magasins répartis sur toute la france et
devient ainsi une nouvelle solution pour
vos déplacements en vallée de chevreuse